>> Cleron: Hi, my name is Mike Cleron. I’m
an engineer on the Android Development team.
Android is an open software platform for mobile
development. It is intended to be a complete
stack that includes everything from the operating
system through middleware and up through applications.
Now, I’m going to talk about how Android
can achieve smooth integration of components
that are written by different authors as user
navigates forward and backward through the
experience. In Android, every application
runs in its own process. There’s a lot of
benefits to this. It gives you security, protected
memory. It means that an application is doing
something CPU intensive, won’t block other
critical activities, like, answering a phone.
So, all applications are running in their
own processes and the Android system itself
is responsible for starting these processes
and shutting them down as necessary to reclaim
resources. I have an example that shows how
that works. Now, to explain this example,
let me set up the scenario. In this example,
the user is going to navigate from the home
screen to their inbox in the mail application.
They’re going to select a mail message,
from the mail message, they’re going to
follow a link out to some Web content in the
browser, and then from the browser, they’re
going to click on something that takes them
in to the maps application which is a not
unreasonable scenario. Now, when they do this,
they’re going to actually navigate through
four different applications running in four
different processes that are potentially written
by four different authors. From the users
point of view, none of that is important.
What they want is to be able to navigate forward,
clicking on what they want to click on, getting
the component they want to have responding
to each click, and then they want to be able
to go backwards and get back to where they
were. And in particular, they don’t want
to have to worry about which applications
are running, how much memory they’ve consumed,
how much memory is left on the device, whether
they can launch that next process because
all the resources have been taken up. So the
Android system manages all that for them.
Here’s how it works. At the start, the user
is on the homepage, there are two processes,
in this example, that are running. There’s
the system process which contains the activity
manager. That contains the common backstack
that is used by all activities, regardless
of which process they run in, and then the
home process is running and that has the home
activity running inside it. Now, before launching
the mail application, the system is going
to save the state of the home application
just in case, anything bad happens to it,
and you’ll see that bad stuff in a few minutes.
So the home application has saved that state
in a little parcel that has been moved to
the system process. And at that point, the
system can create the mail process, we can
then launch the mail list activity into that
process, and now that’s what the user is
seeing on the screen, their mail list. If
they click on a particular mail message, then
that creates a request to launch the next
activity that goes to the system process.
Again, before a new activity is launched,
we save the state of the last activity, so
the mail list saves its state into the system
process. It’s worth noting that the state
that it saves is not every message in your
inbox, it’s meta information about the current
state of the activity. Things like, where
you are scrolled to in the list; which item
is selected. You don’t have to store the
complete mail list in that parcel. So now,
that the information has been saved, then
the system is free to launch the next activity
that shows a particular mail message and now
that is what the user sees on the screen.
From the mail message, they then click on
a link to go out to the Web. So again, another
request is created. The state of the currently
running activity is saved in the system process,
and now, we need to create a process to run
the browser in. So we launch the browser process,
we launch the browser activity into that process
and the user is now looking at the browser.
We’re going to do this one time where the
user clicks on a link in the browser to launch
a map. We create the request. We save the
state of the foreground activity, in this
case the browser, and we would like to launch
the maps application but, as you can see,
we’re out of room. So, in order to launch
the maps application, we have to find a process
that we can kill. We don’t want to kill
the home application because we use that for
a navigation hub, we want that to be always
available, so it’s always responsive. We
don’t want to kill the browser because that’s
the activity the user just came from. But
the mail application is a few frames back
on the backstack. No one is looking at it.
It’s a perfect candidate to kill, and so
it’s gone. Now, that the mail application
is gone, we can create the maps process, and
in the maps process, we can create the maps
activity and now the user is looking at the
map. So it’s worth noting that all of this
happened without the user being aware of any
of the machinery from the user’s point of
view. They click on mail, they went to mail.
They click on the message, they went to a
message. They click from the message to the
Web, they went to the Web. From the Web, they
click on a map, they went to a map. The fact
that these are different processes, different
applications, different developers, it’s
invisible to the user which is as it should
be. Now, the reason we saved all those little
pieces of state information, in the system
process is so that we can go backwards and
the user can navigate backwards as seamlessly
as they navigated forward. So, from the current
state, if the user hits back, the first thing
that we’re going to do is pop the maps application
off the top of the activity stack and restore
the browser. The browser doesn’t actually
need to restore its state because it’s the
same object so, at this point, we can just
discard the saved state that was stored in
the system process. And now the user is looking
at the browser, that’s the foreground activity.
If they hit back again, they are expecting
to go back to the mail message that they came
from. Unfortunately, the mail process isn’t
running anymore. So the first thing we have
to do is make space to run the mail application.
We do that by killing the maps process and
starting the mail process. Once we’ve done
that, we can then launch a fresh copy of the
message activity. This is a new copy that
doesn’t have any of the state that the user
saw when they left. In order to get it back
into the state that the user is expecting,
we then take that saved parcel of information
from the system process and we restore the
state of the message activity. Once we’ve
done that, it’s ready to be shown to the
user. We can pop the browser off the top of
the activity stack, show them the message
activity and they’re back where they started.
If we do that one more time, if we hit back
again from the mail message to go back to
the mail list, we don’t have to create a
new process because this one is still running
in the mail process, we just create a new
instance of the mail list activity, that again
is a fresh activity to restore its state.
We take the state from the system process.
Give that back to the mail list. Now the mail
list is in the same state that it was when
the user left. We can pop the message and
the user back where they came from. So the—what
this example is showing is that the user can
navigate forwards and backwards through multiple
activities, they’re running multiple processes,
they’re provided by multiple developers,
and have a very seamless experience because
the android framework is doing the hard work
of launching and shutting down processes to
manage resources and making sure that the
state is preserved as the user expects. If
you’re interested in finding out more about
Android, I encourage you to visit the developer
site and download the SDK. In the SDK, you’ll
find a lot more documentation, and sample
code, and you’ll also be able to try building
applications of your own. There’s also a
developer group that you can join to find
out more information, and I also encourage
you to check back frequently because we’ll
be posting updates to the SDK as the platform
matures. Thank you for watching.